never buy a thing seduced by its
cheapness
such a thing in the long run will cost
you dearly
the only place where success comes
before work
is in the dictionary
beware of little expenses
a small leak will sink a great ship
[Music]
every day is a bank account and time is
our currency
no one is Rich no one is poor
we've got 24 hours each
lessons in life will be repeated
until they are learned
opportunity is missed by most people
because it is dressed in overalls and
looks like work
money is a terrible master
but an excellent servant
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
rather go to bed without dinner than to
rise in debt
[Music]
having been poor is no shame
but being ashamed of it is
care about what other people think
and you will always be their prisoner
don't think money does everything or you
are going to end up doing everything for
money
it's not the mistake that matters
it's how you interpret the lesson
every time you borrow money
you're robbing your future self
choose a job you love
and you will never have to work a day in
your life
control your finances or lack of them
will control you
look at life through the windshield
not the rear view mirror
do more
the race is won by the horse that
outstrips its Rivals by a head
many people take no care of their money
till they come early to the end of it
and others do just the same with their
time
you can't go back and change the
beginning
but you can start where you are and
change the ending
if you want to succeed you should strike
out on New Paths
rather than travel the worn Paths of
accepted success
too many people spend money they haven't
earned
to buy things they don't want
to impress people that they don't like
don't repeat their mistakes
the secret to success is to do the
common things uncommonly well
you get in life what you have the
courage to ask for
don't spend money you don't have
if you work hard enough
one day you'll reach a point where you
don't work for money
life is available only in the present
that is why we should walk in such a way
that every step can bring us to the Here
and Now
opportunity does not knock it presents
itself when you beat down the door
the root of all evil is not money
but the lack of money
life is like a play
it's not the length but the Excellence
of the acting that matters
the way to get started is to quit
talking and begin doing
money grows on the tree of persistence
think of each failure each heartache and
each loss in your life as a lesson in
Courage and resilience
we must be willing to let go of the life
we've planned
so as you have the life that is waiting
for us
the poorest man I know is the man who
has nothing but money
a friendship founded on business
is better than a business founded on
friendship
life is a shipwreck but we must not
forget tossing in the lifeboats
give a bowl of rice to a man and you
will feed him for a day
teach him how to grow his own rice
and you will save his life
money is only a tool
it will take you wherever you wish
but it will not replace you as the
driver
we cannot become what we need to buy
remaining what we are
if your only goal is to become rich
you will never achieve it
the life we receive is not short but we
make it so
we are not ill provided but use what we
have wastefully
one day your life will Flash before your
eyes
make sure it's worth watching
he who works all day has no time to make
money
the trouble is if you don't spend your
life yourself
other people spend it for you
life is a succession of lessons which
must be lived to be understood
if you want to get rich think of saving
as earning
quality means doing it right when no one
is looking
don't be pushed around by the fears in
your mind
be led by the dreams in your heart
spend your money on the things money can
buy
spend your time on the things money
can't buy
don't bite off more than you can chew
because nobody looks attractive spitting
it back out
if we command our wealth
we shall be rich and free
if our wealth commands us
we are indeed poor
we make a living by what we get
we make a Life by what we give
lend money in front of witnesses
give money without them
learn from the mistakes of others
you can't live long enough to make them
all yourself
the hardest thing to learn in life is
which bridge to cross
and which Bridge To Burn
a comfort zone is a wonderful place
but nothing ever grows there
anything you can settle with money is
cheap
watch for big problems
they disguise big opportunities
so far you've survived 100 of your bad
days
this too shall pass
the best way to become poor is finding a
job that will suck the life out of you
when life gives you lemons
make lemonade
don't cry because it's over
smile because it happened
you make mistakes mistakes don't make
you
do not lend money to relatives because
you will lose both
Letting Go does not mean you stop caring
it means you stop trying to force others
to
why let go of yesterday
because yesterday has already let go of
you
the more your money works for you the
less you have to work for money
do a good job you don't have to worry
about the money it will take care of
itself
just do your best work then try to trump
it
a wise person should have money in their
head
but not in their heart
a man must be big enough to admit his
mistakes
smart enough to profit from them
and strong enough to correct them
speed of your success is limited only by
your dedication
and what you're willing to sacrifice
[Music]
no man becomes rich unless he enriches
others
the chief danger in life is that you may
take too many precautions
yesterday is not ours to recover
but tomorrow is ours to win or lose
all you have to do is pay attention
lessons always arrive when you are ready
money makes the world go around but
don't let it make you dizzy
the success of each is dependent upon
the success of the other
we are products of our past
but we don't have to be prisoners of it
success comes from keeping the ears open
and the mouth closed
life is ten percent what happens to you
and ninety percent how you react
money grows on skills
not trees
your life improves once you realize no
one cares
accept yourself
love yourself and keep moving forward
if you want to fly you have to give up
what weighs you down
be humble to those who praise you
Pleasant to those who honor you
kind to those who cherish you
good to those who love you and generous
to those who adore you
wealth like happiness is never attained
when sought after directly
it comes as a byproduct of providing a
useful service
you can learn more in one hour of doing
than 10 hours of listening
sometimes the hardest part isn't letting
go
but rather learning to start over
you should have ways of making money
that other people know nothing of
a man should never neglect his family
for business
the only beautiful path is the one you
create
taking money never gets boring
giving money gets boring quickly
you don't learn to walk by following
rules
you'll learn by doing
and by falling over
it is wrong to assume that men of
immense wealth are always happy
[Music]
the whole secret of a successful life is
to find out what is one's Destiny to do
and then do it
fear is not a good teacher
the lessons of fear are quickly
forgotten
two classes of people lose money
those who are too weak to guard what
they have
those who win money by Trick
they both lose in the end
there Comes A Time in your life when you
have to choose to turn the page
write another book or simply close it
we cannot change the past
we can only take action in the present
and therefore
change the future
good judgment comes from experience
and experience comes from bad judgment
foreign